[موسيقى]
أمامي ليجر دينو باكرز وينج اليابان
عجلات السلطة على الفاكهة وركوب 4 ق ADB إلى
انظر لفعل ذلك الاسم الطويل
أمامي أوشيما القراد رذاذ فخر الشيخوخة بصوت للقيام به
أنا
اسمي جيرو أوريتا وأنا أقوم بتدريس السومو للأطفال الذين يطلق عليهم نادي Sumi Ozono Club.
التعاطف أيضا متفرج
[موسيقى]
حسنًا ، الطفل الذي نشأ هنا
آمل أن يصبح تاريخًا عامًا
على قدم المساواة
على شبكة الإنترنت القيام به
اسمي هارت
أنا جومونغ
منذ ان كنت صغيرا
سوف أتدرب مع وعاء طوال الوقت
[موسيقى]
هل هو حجر؟
السيارات
تدرب حقًا وابذل جهدًا
2 ـ التاريخ الموروث
القيام بيتي
أوهأوه
nostre للقيام به
هناك بيان مفصل وأنا أصلع للآلهة
نظرًا لأنه أحد الأقدمين الذين يجب أن يأخذوا السومو في كل تطبيق
بالإضافة إلى بيرين في الصناعات التي يشارك فيها الجميع ، من الأطفال الصغار إلى الأعمال الدرامية
القيام به من أجل stap 4 sports pig antique ee amu pi with Miya official Affairs
جيتي رودو
كلما كانت القرية أصغر ، كلما تحول المهرجان إلى إعصار
لا يزال موروثًا ويقف في التقاليد
أشياء لا أستطيع تركها في حياتي
لقد أصبح شيئًا مهمًا
همم
[موسيقى]